you may remember it was about a month
ago when we had an NHS phone in in which
patients and Medics alike shared their
stories of the Health Service well the
legendary singer sir Rod Stewart was so
moved by some of the stories that he
heard that he rang in with a generous
offer let's just remind you of that
moment
yesterday I went for my yearly scan
which is private obviously and I was 20
minutes late and I phoned in I said I'm
terribly sorry I'll be there was a half
an hour late I phoned him I got in there
and they said I said I'm so sorry I'm so
late I said oh we're not busy at all
we've only got a couple of customers
today I won't tell you where it was but
my point being this is ridiculous you
know and I I would like to pay 10 by 10
or 20 scans I don't know how we're going
to work this out and hopefully some
other people will follow
foreign
we didn't just let him leave it at that
we did follow up with him and sir rod
I'm pleased to say has been true to his
word in an interview today he's told Sky
News that he backs pay Rises for both
nurses and Junior doctors while warning
against a move towards a U.S style
Health Care system
now he's funded a day's worth of scans
at a mobile unit in Essex and arrived in
style as you might expect this morning
to meet some of the people who are
benefiting he spoke to Skye's Sarah Jane
me on the day I spoke to you I just come
back from my scan in a private clinic in
Harley Street and I walked in I said I'm
terribly terribly sorry I'm half hour
late I said oh and I was okay we haven't
got anybody in here today there's eight
people there with not hardly anything to
do and then I thought this is a terrible
Injustice so here we are but Sarah I'm
here not to talk about politics please
because otherwise it overshadows what
we're trying to do yeah okay last time
we spoke well you tapped into something
yeah didn't you that's the thing I mean
we won't get political but you probably
said well a lot of people at home were
thinking and calling into us to say but
because of your platform it created
headlines and you wouldn't make some
noise right you want to make some noise
about the state of the NHS absolutely I
do and you know I just don't want to do
it here if this is a big success because
I think it will be a night to do it in
in Belfast Dublin Edinburgh Glasgow
Manchester and just keep it going I hope
some other people follow me because I
want to improve
I am not all mouth and trousers and
that's why I'm here to prove that I've
followed through with it okay Bo yeah
well it just took a
couple of weeks in fact from that phone
call to being here in Harlow today so
talk to us about what's behind you and
what you're providing for people today
and so this is the mobile scanning unit
and up to 20 people are going to get
scans thanks to your generous donation
too yeah yeah that's it so hopefully
these are people that are trouble
finding trouble to get a scam either
because of the backlog or because lack
of finances so here I am the night in
China and I am a knight by the way and
that's why I feel I want to do good
things yeah I'm not doing it with
publicity I'm getting off of that yeah
that's the thing you did say when we
spoke and you just said it again Ned
that you hope this would spark something
that other people would see what you
were doing and make similar generous
suggestions yeah you're in a fortunate
position right and you were upfront
about that you said you can afford to do
this so you are but
you do think that's not sustainable it
shouldn't come to this should it it
shouldn't take sir Rod Stewart coming in
on his White Horse to provide scams
white roles
whatever it takes though it shouldn't
but you know we've got to sort this out
it's we're in Dire Straits here I mean
if I'm going to get political I think we
should send the ukrainians some f-16s
that's up to you prime minister yeah you
can't sort that one out now well I wish
I could I mean I've been supporting them
for years ukrainians on stage I have the
flag and I wear a blue and yellow suit
and do a song and dedicate it to them
and feel very strongly about it because
if the ukrainians lose
it's the end of civilization as we know
it you know it's all over so f-16s
please yeah you think you don't want to
get political but everyday life is
political isn't it when you talk about
what's going on in Ukraine what's going
on in the NHS so
in that respect you know for credit to
you if you're using your platform and
just saying what you think you're not
pulling any punches you're not mincing
your words you're just being
refreshingly honest because you can be
yeah I can be how old do you want me to
get how much time have we got and you're
going to meet some people here today
they're going to benefit from these
scans today and obviously you've been
through a similar experience yourself
what kind of words of reassurance we
give people that are starting on a
journey you've been on and they're
continuing on because it's something you
always live with yeah it is something
you always live with you do again this
amazing appreciation of life when you
have a cancer scale like I did of cancer
in the throat and the Azure fathers
um but you know fight the good fight
that's all you can do stay active don't
lay home in bed you know you just got to
keep on working and doing what you're
doing and
pray to God yeah and it's hard isn't it
because again like you said you know we
made headlines because you just tapped
into a national mood and you said it
plainly and simply and that caught on I
think it's something like 92 of the
British public think that the current
plan is a working something's got to
give and that something isn't enhs how
important is is it that we fight you
know for the NHS so that it's free for
everyone oh absolutely it you know it's
uh when was it full 1945 just when I was
born
hard to imagine Britain without the NHS
because when you talk about being proud
of our country
people list a lot of things and the NHS
is always up yeah you know if we don't
have the NHS it'll be like the United
States but I've lived there for 30 odd
years and if you get yourself in trouble
car accidents and you can't just go into
an emergency when you go into an
emergency they say right we've got some
of your documents and you know it's
unbelievable in America it doesn't work
there either but I think it's working
better there than it is here at the
moment and we must pull it together yeah
they're not going to be huge with it for
British Society it would just change the
face of things yeah people don't have
access to so not all mouth and trousers
you would definitely just a
over question because I know that you
want to go in and meet the people that
are going to be carrying out these
things from the patients here what would
your message be to NHS staff because it
is grim it's not getting any better
Junior doctors are going on strike as
well since we last spoke which has got
even worse so what would you say to them
to sort of boost their morale if you
hang in there hang in there I think one
of the junior doctors came back with a
counter offer which I don't know the
number but I find it to be reasonable
there must be enough money in the
coffers to play up for these nurses only
two years ago we were clapping and now
lesson they work so hard saw the Earth
you're going to keep supporting people
like you said you wanna
start this as a trial and perhaps do
more and you know this is a long-term
relationship between you and the NHS in
terms of giving back I sense from from
the conversations we've had yeah it is
yeah I mean I've used the nhf many times
when I was little with an ingrowing
toenail they took good care of me when I
was six they literally cover everything
they do yeah even ingrown toenails and
so what's do it absolutely thank you so
much for um
would be over the moon I better ring
ahead okay thanks everyone